It's been a full on year
for me and Nikki.
Ups and downs, finally
defrosted the fridge.
Gave serious
consideration
to starting yoga.
Honestly I've never
been closer.
Also, oh yeah...
it turns out we
can't have kids.
So, we're gonna adopt.
No!
Talk to your children!
They're not
my children!
Yeah that was big.
It will be fine though
as long as we keep
our heads.
Our family is
really encouraging.
Certain things you
don't get second hand
Underwear,
children.
Our support network
couldn't be more
positive.
My kids suck every
ounce of energy
out of me
until I'm nothing but
an empty carcass.
And we got
approved!
No bother at all,
sailed right through.
Communication would
be at the top, right,
And then you got
honesty underneath it.
But the
communication
sort of encompasses
both of them.
Um...
Actually don't worry
Nikki is eyeballing me.
Right.
You're up to date.